le calme après la tempête à la
chapelle-sur-erdre il est 9h45 ce
vendredi quand un individu se présente
au poste de police de cette commune de
20000 habitants et agresse une policière
à l'aide d'un couteau
après la fuite de l'agresseur
une chasse à l'homme est lancée quelques
250 gendarmes et une équipe du gign de
nantes sont déployés trois heures plus
tard le suspect est interpellé
mais succombe à ses blessures après un
échange de tirs avec les forces de
l'ordre rapidement
gérald darmanin seront sur place pour
prendre des nouvelles de la policière et
on dira un peu plus sur le profil de
l'agresseur
il sortait de prison et en 2016 il avait
été signalé pour une pratique rigoriste
de l'islam pour radicalisation et
étaient ainsi inscrits au fichier fs prt
et il était reconnu diagnostiqué comme
schizophrène sévère il avait un
traitement médical connu des services de
police l'individu faisait l'objet d'un
suivi médical mais le motif de son acte
reste encore flou déjà cette nouvelle
agression d'une policière fait débat
l'opposition veut des explications
elles demandent comment un individu
radicaliser et fichez a pu agir en toute
impunité
les syndicats de police eux aussi sont
exaspérés et attendent des réponses sait
encore s'il preuve en est besoin que les
forces de sécurité intérieure
aujourd'hui même la police municipale
qui est dans le dans le continuum de
sécurité avec la police et la
gendarmerie sont aujourd'hui des cibles
alors des cibles non seulement de
terroristes mais également des
délinquants de droit commun
donc c'est vraiment aujourd'hui une
priorité pour nous que l'état en
prennent conscience et protège mieux ses
forces de l'ordre des attaques dont le
ministre de la justice eric dupond
moretti s'est défendu et s'il ya des
failles
je dirai ce que j'ai à dire et je ferai
ce que j'ai à faire mais en l'état je
vous redis que cet homme a purgé sa
peine qu'il n'y a pas eu d'aménagement
un suivi socio judiciaire qu'il a
respecté dans notre pays quand un homme
a purgé sa peine il a purgé sa peine et
quand il a un suivi socio judiciaire
il est tenu de respecter ce qui semble
être le cas
cette agression intervient le jour même
de l'envoi de la circulaire du ministre
de la justice aux magistrats le garde
des sceaux leur demande de faire preuve
de fermeté à l'encontre de ceux reconnus
coupables d' attaques contre des
policiers
eric dupond moretti qui souhaitent aussi
que chacune de ses attaques fasse
rapidement l'objet d'un passage devant
les tribunaux une demande comme une main
tendue aux policiers avec lesquels les
relations du ministre de la justice
reste compliqué